الان طفله بقى لها فوق 35 ساعه الان هي
محاصره بين الجسس
والشهداء في البرد القارس بين الكلاب
الضاله بهاء حماده هند كانت راكبه مع
اخويا في السياره اثناء نزوح من مكان لاخر
فوجئ اخوي هو ماشي في السياره انه
الدبابات قدامه اطلقوا النار عليه بصوره
مباشره حاولنا لاتصال نتطمن عليه بعد
ساعتين ونن بنحاول الاتصال ردت علي بنت و
ليان قالت لي انا يا عمي ابوي وا وامي
واختي استشهدوا ضاي انا وهند فقلت لها
تقلقيش تخافيش انا الان ببعت لك اسعاف يجي
ياخذك من مكان اللي انت فيه خليكي مكانك
تتحركي قالت لي انا مصابه في رجلي فقلت
لها تقلقي الان مش حيطول عليك الاسعاف ان
شاء الله فقمنا بالتواصل مع الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني اخذ الرقم منا وتواصل مع
الشهيده ليان انه يهدئ من روعها ويديها
الارشادات الاوليه عشان الاصابه اللي كانت
فيها واصابتها كانت في رجليها اصابه بسيطه
يعني مش كثيره اثناء الحديث وهو بيتحدث
معها فقد الاتصال معها حاولنا نرن عليها
نرن عليها ردت علي اللي هي حفيدتي هند
وقالت لي انه ليان اي استشهدت وهند لا
تتجاوز الست سنوات حاولنا الاتصال مع
الهلال
الفلسطيني الهل الفلسطيني اخذ تنسيق من
الاسرائيليين من جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي
انه الساعه 6:00 راحت سياره الاسعاف على
المنطقه عشان تخلي الطفله طفله طبعا كانت
في هذاك الوقت مش مصابه هي ظلينا نتواصل
مع البنت حتى الساعه احنا خسه بعد الساعه
خسه مساء قطع الاتصال يعني يبدو انه
بطاريه الجوال اللي بتحكي منه فصلت الساعه
6ه وصل واحنا مع تواصل مع الاسعاف ومع
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني فقد
الاتصال ايش صار مع الطفله او وين صارت
ايش صار فيها هل هو استلمها الاسعاف او ما
استلمها جنود الاحتلال اخذوا البنت او ما
اخذوها نحن ما بنعرف الان ننا بناشد احرار
العالم بناشد الصليب الاحمر بناشد هيئه
حقوق الانسان او ما يدعي بهيئه حقوق
الانسان بناشد كل انسان شريف وحر بيقدر
يساعد هالطفله البريئه من الماساه اللي هي
فيها اللي انا لا اظن انها تعيش يعني ب
بحاله نفسيه بعد هذا العمر كل هيته بحاله
نفسيه طبيعيه من اللي شافته الان طفله بقى
لها فوق ال 35 ساعه الان هي محاصره بين
الجسس
والشهداء في البرد القارس بين الكلاب
الضاله وانا استغرب انه قبل سنتين كان في
حدث في العالم انه طفل وقع في بئر جميع
قنوات العالم كانت متجهه 24 ساعه
كاميراتها وبتحكي في الطفل هذا جميع دول
العالم هبت لمساعده الطفل قامت بارسال
المساعدات وارسال الاليات وارسال
للاسعافات لنجدد هذا الطفل هل هذا الطفل
يختلف عن هذه الطفله هل هذه الطفله تشكل
خطر على العالم باسره او على اي انسان في
العالم